the unhappy autumn likewise autumn
welcome to a new edition of las
vegas nao in spanish of health to natalia
badly had today we start everything to find
the latest from the world of
entertainment the countdown to
the billboard latin music awards has
already begun  and it is that it will
have iconic presentations by
various artists such as marc anthony
nat and natasha caro and prince royce nicky
jam as you are seeing and much more, the
rehearsals by these artists were
carried out throughout this week
and I had the  opportunity to speak with
prince royce about his presentation this
thursday
the idea for the deeply use a
lot of colors as we did with the video
it is seen in the video well as they are
different color folk and my goal of how
he will project the same in karina
lenta vicent harina  come in and me tonight
to project like what color happiness
are pacs over against
that's how it is prince royce is nominated for
a total of 5 categories  including
song of the year for his single carita
inocento the
award ceremony rather of the
billboard latin music awards will
take place this thursday, september 23 before
the world we
continue talking about
live music and this time we talk about
music here  live in las vegas' and the
long-awaited concert by ricky martin
jerry iglesias will arrive at the mgm grand
garden flour this saturday starting
at seven thirty at
night tonight is promised to be full of
surprises that will also feature a
presentation  del cantante goes
backwards there are still a little bit of tickets
available and you can find them via
ticketmaster dotcom
also in september we are
celebrating hispanic heritage month and what
better way to do it than with a
local restaurant called makers
inc finders marta molina  you are
accompanying us from that restaurant
welcome to marta thank you when you
tell us a little about your story and
the history  finders migration ia well it
started in 2014 when my son joshua
came with the idea that he wanted to open a
coffee shop and then he showed us the
concept it took us where he wanted to open
it and we decided to support him and the
construction of buses without end of
semester and  It started on main street' and
now they have three locations, right? Yes,
we have the other one, it's in summer link in
the summer link stores and we have a
bakery called t crisis in spray,
keep and wind road and right now we're in
area 15, incredible, what a great way  to
represent our heritage and our
Hispanic culture, Latin culture, tell me
a little bit about what we have here, I already know what they
are, they are called empanadas, but tell us
a little bit if the empanadas
originate from Colombia, where I am from, and
are very typical, here we have
completely vegetarian empanadas
and also our
different empanadas that come with cheese meat
shrimp chicken and with their different
sauces are very very common t
We also have there the bandeja paisa which
is called the bandeja paisa
in this the meat is the most ripe the
egg and here we have the black beans
with their yellow rice and their eggs
clearly it is very typical of Colombia and
these are just things not even
we have just scratched the surface of all
that you have to offer in
microsoft finers and besides
representing the hispanic culture colombian culture you
are helping a good
cause tell us a little bit more about
chicanos por la causa if we are
helping you contributing we made a
special menu  for this hispanic heritage month
starting september 15 october 15 and
we have a special menu and give
that menu 20 dollars per dish and 5 dollars
of that 20 we are donating chicanos
for the cause also october first
we have salsa in mainstream and also 20
percent  of what that night will
also contribute to chicanos for the
perfect cause a great cause we are
celebrating the month of  hispanic heritage
as a great restaurant with several
places as you already know
I leave you the information on chicanos for
the cause
the brunch menu consists of three
different options from which you can
enjoy a coffee of your choice a
perfect pudding and its dish the enj
hay  vegan leaves all this costs 20
dollars per person and of these 20 5
will be donated to Chicanos for the cause
and remember you have until
October 15 to take advantage of this good
cause by makers in finders
well here you have reached your edition of
the  vegas' lado in spanish don't forget
to visit and ilustrado dotcom in case you
need more information about these
events and more thank you very much for your
attention see you next week
greets you natalia bad sound
[Music]